الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون يواجه
اعمال شغب واحتجاجات تعتبر من اصعب
التحديات التي مرت عليه في ولايته
الرئاسيه الثانيه فكيف واجه ماكرون هذا
التحدي ماكرون قام بتاجيل زيارته الرسميه
لالمانيا رغم انها كانت ستكون الزياره
الاولى لرئيس فرنسيا لالمانيا منذ 23 عاما
الرئيس الفرنسي كان قد خرج لتوهه من معركه
سياسيه بين كتله اليسار وكتله اليمين
المتشدد نجح فيها برفع الحد الادنى
القانوني للتقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما
والاحتجاجات هذه اعطت كلا الطرفين فرصه
للانتقاص من اداره ماكرون السياسيه للبلاد
ولم يكن هذا التحدي الاول من نوعه بالنسبه
لماكرون فقد شهد على احتجاجات السترات
الصفراء التي ملات الشوارع في 2018 لكن
العنف هذه المره مختلف لكونه مرتبطا
بطبيعه العمل الشرطي في فرنسا ووجود
الاسلحه الناريه بحوزه شرطه المرور الرئيس
الفرنسي اليوم يحاول ان لا يكرر سيناريو
عام 2005 حينما شهدت فرنسا اعمال شغب
ليليه واسعه النطاق اضطرت معها الحكومه
لفرض حاله طوارئ لمده ثلاثه اسابيع حتى
استعادت السيطره لكن ماكرون يحاولون نشر
قوات النظام بشكل متدرجا في الشارع لعله
يتمكن من احتواء الازمه في الوقت المناسب